who's up for celebrating world wildlife
day tomorrow how about a stop at the
henderson bird viewing preserve a great
spot to catch
local and migratory birds and safely
enjoy nature of course
we join rocky theist once again to teach
us how to bird watch properly yeah the
valley apparently is a hot spot for
birding which is the proper
terminology for bird watching you know
want to educate you guys out there so
first and foremost
to properly bird here what do you need
let's go down the checklist so if you
want to come out to the henderson bird
viewing preserve i would wear lots of
sunscreen
check bring plenty of water with you
okay
some sort of sun protection is always
recommended
don't have to tell me twice to put a hat
on i love that and of course if you have
your own binoculars you can bring them
with you but if you don't we've got some
loner pairs as well
perfect and then when you come we have a
checklist of all the over 200 species of
birds that you might see while you're
out here cool and of course that's
seasonal right yep so on our checklist
we've got a couple keys for you the
first one is the status that will tell
you if it's a resident bird
summer visitor migrant winner visitor
and how common or likely it is that you
are to see the birds so is it abundant
common
rare or undefined that we hope we would
see it here but maybe nobody's actually
ever spotted it and then it's done while
you well you tell us
which birds are our usual or normal
during the season i'm going to try and
find some okay okay great so uh looking
out at the water right now you might be
seeing some ruddy ducks
yeah goose up in the trees you may see
some hummingbirds and some finches today
oh wow the american avastad is another
common bird that we see here and if you
want up-to-date information you can
always go on
ebird.com and put in henderson bird
viewing preserve and birders will post
the birds that they saw that day so you
know what to expect
that's cool and of course obviously that
sounds like a lot of passion people are
really
into birding so let's talk about the
culture and the community of birding
and apparently how this is the hot spot
for it yeah so birding is an
international
sport or hobby if you will we get lots
of international visitors
every year every month more
international visitors than local
perhaps oh wow
we're trying to change that today it's a
great local spot for birding obviously
there's not a lot of
water in the area so we have nine ponds
here that
uh hundreds of species of birds will
come and hang out here and he said
there's bird watching
competitions absolutely there's a
national international birding
competitions we've had birders come here
and practice their birding before a big
competition out east
okay so if you're not you know
technically a birder and you're not here
to practice your bird watching for
competition it's also just a really
great place
to have a peaceful safe social distance
activity with your family or with the
day whoever whatever
right absolutely we have over 100 acres
here we have soft and hard surface
trails so we've got something for
everybody benches throughout the
facility
so come out and just enjoy some serenity
in nature
i love it i will send it back to you
guys
all right where are you at teddy i see i
think i see you
i spot i spot brian loftus over here to
the left
a great day for bird watching you guys
actually i was like
all of us we should go bird watch and
this is a great place to do it right
it is weather's nice nine pawns count
them nine
nine okay that's it there's no excuse
you gotta check it out for yourself